au parc des princes david beckham n'a
pas montré le bout de son nez
pourtant la salle de conférence était
pleine comme un oeuf l'attaquant du psg
zlatan ibrahimovic prenant le relais
devant les micros une question
d'expérience de ces rencontres au sommet
comme ce quart de finale de ligue des
champions face à barcelone
souvent transparent lors des grands
matches le meilleur buteur de ligue 1 ne
devra pas se louper face à son ancien
club à cinq est tombé à défaut je pense
que ce sera un match très difficile car
on va affronter la meilleure équipe est
probablement la meilleure de tous les
temps qui dénonce au fbi de genk faute
professionnelle et on sait très bien que
barcelone aime garder le ballon mais
mais nous aurons des occasions car nous
jouons à domicile
alors comment gagner face à la meilleure
équipe du monde et surtout arrêter
lionel messi le quadruple ballon d'or
auteur déjà de 56 buts cette saison il
faudra certainement imiter le milan ac
au tour précédent et défendre en bloc
quoi qu'il en soit carlo ancelotti ne
compte pas changer ses plans tactiques
espère voir le meilleur de ses joueurs
je vais contre pas à ça et est dirigée
par toutes les équipes mais je voudrais
avoir un paris saint-germain courage aux
personnalités qu'elle va jouer le match
peut-être que nous aurons pas beaucoup
de possession nous avons la possession
j'espère des warm équipe il a de bonnes
idées à claire pour jouer pour un
attaquer pour marquer pour gagner
à quelques heures du plus grand match de
leur vie les joueurs à paris saint
germain semblent sereins rire et
décontraction règne à l'entraînement ou
david beckham était une nouvelle fois le
premier sur le terrain aux portes du
camp des loges à saint-germain-en-laye
plusieurs dizaines de passionnés les
attendent et malgré l'everest qui se
dressent devant le psg il y croit
j'espère déjà relève surtout qu'on en
ruine pas nos chances pour le match
retour qu'on regarde des chances moins
ne pas perdre ne pas perdre serait déjà
bien comme ça en garde des chances pour
le match retour
j'ai ensuite on sait jamais quand le
barça moi je pense qu'il faut il faut il
faut jouer si on est trop derrière n'ont
eu 2011 de jeu derrière ces noms pris 4
fait faut jouer vous jouez faut par po2
faut jouer les presser au milieu en fait
je crois ça va être un match dur c'est
difficile mais pas impossible sans jouer
les coups à fond
y'a pas de raison qu'on perde mais ça va
pas être facile de marcher
ce soir les joueurs de carlo ancelotti
sentiront sûrement le poids de
l'histoire celle d'un club qui ne s'est
hissée qu'une seule fois en quarts de
finale de la coupe d'europe c'était en